und bei uns im studio ist der bild
chefredakteur johannes wo ihr mann ist
willkommen mal wieder zu dir über aus
deiner sicht den zusammengefasst was ist
da letzte nacht passiert es war eine
dramatische nacht alles begann also die
phase der allergrößten erhitzung begann
mit der rede putins einer rede voller
lügen voller propaganda die in den
letzten wochen hat systematisch
verbreiten und vorbereiten lassen wir
haben immer wieder auch bilder in den
sozialen medien gesehen die ganz klar
gemacht haben das was dort gerade
explodiert ist haben die russen selber
in die luft gesprengt diese behauptung
die die russen tätigen lässt sich anhand
der realität ganz einfach widerlegen und
all diese propaganda hat er dann gestern
zusammengefasst und hat dann zum schluss
eben fast wie nebenbei verkündet dass er
diese beiden gebiete die zur ukraine
gehören als unabhängig anerkannt das war
der erste schritt und in der redaktion
haben wir uns dann schon gedacht mal
gucken wie lange es jetzt bis zum
zweiten schritt dauert der absehbar war
weil man eben auch erahnen kann wie
diese tricks die den kriegsbeginn
legitimieren sollen ablaufen und siehe
da es dauerte gar nicht lange es war
eine frage von minuten
als dann die prorussischen rebellen
innerhalb der ukraine erklärt haben
finden wir gut und wir sprechen russland
unsere freundschaft aus und nachdem das
geschehen war kam es dann nur wenige
stunden später zum dritten schritt den
alle gefürchtet hatten von dem auch
internationale diplomaten und
staatschefs immer noch gehofft haben
dass er ausbleiben würde nämlich dass
diese so genannten volksrepublik die
eigentlich ein teil der ukraine sind um
militärische hilfe gebeten haben
russland und putin dann auch sofort
gesagt hat dem kommen wir nach und das
ist jetzt sozusagen soll sozusagen die
legitimation für den einmarsch in der
souveräne land ukraine seien ja auch
gerade die bilder die uns aus der nacht
erreicht haben über twitter und auch
plattform wie ethik talk zum beispiel
johannes du schreibst in deinem sehr
bewegenden kommentar online bei bild.de
mit der überschrift putin ist die jetzt
unser feind und die betonung liegt da
glaube ich auf dem wort jetzt erklären
noch mal was dich zu dieser überschrift
bewegt hat naja zum einen muss man die
historische herleitung der situation
oder die herleitung der situation über
die letzten jahre beachten putin hat
etwas aufgebaut dass man gelenkte
demokratie nennt das ist keine
lupenreine diktatur dass es keine ganz
klare autokratie aber jetzt geht er eben
noch mal einen schritt ganz klar in die
richtung unrechtmäßiger herrscher greift
ein anderes land an das ist die eine
ebene und da sind wir natürlich als
demokratie als teil des freien westens
verpflichtet zu sagen da gehen wir nicht
mit mit so einem land brechen wir auch
wenn wir immer versucht haben bis zur
letzten sekunde ja buchstäblich
diplomatische wege aufrecht zu erhalten
das andere und das glaube ich wird auch
die deutsche bevölkerung viel stärker
umtreiben ist dass wir unmittelbar
betroffen sind natürlich die ukraine ist
weit weg aber wir müssen nur auf die
strom und gaspreise gucken wir müssen
auch insgesamt auf die internationalen
märkte gucken die erschüttert sind die
preise gehen hoch es wird wirklich teuer
für die deutschen und dann müssen wir
natürlich auch strategisch sehen
deutschland hat putin zusammen mit
vielen anderen westlichen ländern bei
vielen vielen aggressionen einfach nicht
gestoppt wenn man putin so weitermachen
lässt dann wird er weitermachen denn er
hat das immer wieder gezeigt schon als
er die krim annektiert hat gab es die
hoffnung ja dann ist aber auch wirklich
mal gut aber es war nicht gut und ich
befürchte es wird nun auch nach diesen
beiden gebieten nicht gut sein und er
wird versuchen die ukraine insgesamt
einzunehmen er hat dazu gestern schon
anmerkungen gemacht und was kommt dann
man darf nicht vergessen dass putin auch
an der grenze zur eu auch im baltikum an
der grenze zu direkten nato-staaten die
militärpräsenz erhöht hat dass er seit
vielen jahren nato aufklärungsflügen
über europa in einem luftraum in dem er
nichts verloren hat stört dass er immer
wieder militärisch aggressiv ist und
deswegen betrifft uns das unmittelbar
ich glaube deutschland doch eine
vollkommen neue ostpolitik hier sind wir
viel zu sehr der vergangenheit verhaftet
das war früher mal erfolgreich jetzt
müssen wir sagen russland hat sich
verändert bei allem was gut ist hier ist
schluss und zweitens müssen wir sagen
wir brauchen eine vollkommen neue
verteidigungspolitik das gebaren von
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht in
diesem zusammenhang ist bislang leider
peinlich zu nennen 5000 helm in die
ukraine ist ein witz die helme sind
soweit ich weiß immer noch auf dem weg
zumindest kamen sie nicht in dem
zeitrahmen der vorgesehen war nicht mal
das bekommen wir hin und von unserer
eigenen landesverteidigung die ja auch
ein beitrag zum nato bündnis ist ganz zu
schweigen katastrophe flugzeuge fliegen
nicht boote fahren nicht schwimmen nicht
hier müssen wir ganz dringend
investieren um gucken dass wir ein ernst
zu nehmender start in dieser leider sich
verdüsternden nun aggressiver werdenden
welt werden klare worte von bild
chefredakteur johannes beer vielen dank
dafür